David Boder: [In English] Lohengrinstrasse, the Baltic camp in Munich, September the 21st, 1946. We have on the spool 4 minutes left, but we are going to start with the interview of Mr. Vladus Lukosevicius, [stammers], a Lithuanian. Lithuanian?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Jа.
David Boder: [stammers] ah, who will talk to us in Russian.
David Boder: [In Russian] Аг, сколько вам лет, господин Лукошевичус?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Аг, 13, 13.го года. [1-2 words too weak].
David Boder: Но, сколько вам лет теперь?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Мне сейчас 33 года.
David Boder: 33 года...Ну, вот господин Лукошевичус говорите [здесь?] в этом направлении и прямо сюда в обе стороны...
Vladus Lukosevicius: [1 weak].
David Boder: [В эту и в эту?]
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да.
David Boder: Скажите нам где вы были когда русские пришли в Литванию?
Vladus Lukosevicius: В 39.ом году?
David Boder: Да. [Жизнь?].
Vladus Lukosevicius: Как я [too weak].
David Boder: Нет, где ВЫ были когда русские пришли в Литванию.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Когда русские пришли в Литванию, так я был тогда...я был в польской армии [я, в нашей?], наша страна была [1 weak] область под...Польшей.
David Boder: О, вы были в Польше.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да. Я тогда в польской армии был [и тут?] в Германию в плену...
David Boder: Ага.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . когда [2-3 too weak].
David Boder: [А тогда?], значит тогда мне скажите, где вы были когда война началась? И расскажите мне все.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Когда началась война в 39.ом году?
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Когда, в 39.ом году, когда началась война, то я был 24.го августа я до польской армии мобилизован.
David Boder: Так...Ну, [подождите?] делайте так. Ег, что вы считаете началась война когда немцы пришли в Польшу или когда?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Я считаю началась война в 39.ом году.
David Boder: Это когда что было?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Когда немцы напали на Польшу.
David Boder: Когда немцы о...напали на Польшу?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да.
David Boder: Они...Хорошо, [значит ни что?]. Так, ладно. И вы были где?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Я тогда был в польской армию [взятый?]
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Но и так [1-2 weak] [сентября?] началась война и я был в [1-2 weak/garbled] 13.го сентября попался в Германию в плен и был выезжен в Западнюю Пруссиию.
David Boder: Вы попали в плен...
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да.
David Boder: . . . и вы были [так?] русского...
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Garbled and blocked by Boder]
David Boder: Нет, польского в плен [2-3 garbled and blocked, both speaking at once while Boder tries to correct what he himself is saying.]
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . в Западней Пруссии в Росенберг. Крайс [kreis] это было...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . и Рисенбург [Riesenburg] лагерь.
David Boder: Так. Теперь вы мне все расскажите подробно. Как это вы попали в плен, как вас окружили? Все это расскажите. У нас есть [время?]...Ну?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, я...значит, ну все города уже [немцы заняли от нас?], около Седлец [Siedlce] города 3 километра от города [Седлец?] взяли в плен.
David Boder: Где были ваши офицеры?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Офицеров [у нас не пытал?] убрали и уже с нами не были.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Попадание?] [1-2 garbled] не было. Так, нас первый раз разбили немецкие танки под Варшавой, [недалеко от?] Варшавы, местечка там...[город?] [3-4 garbled].
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, так держали так тогда уже...
David Boder: [1-2 garbled]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Там [blocked by Boder]
David Boder: Не [хватил?] все?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Не, не...[не держали?] только [unknown number of words garbled] [и может?] было держаться против Немцов [и тогда уже?]...
David Boder: [2-3 garbled].
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . [держали?]
David Boder: А вы как остались...[солдат?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: У нас вдруг потом в лесу [1-2 garbled].
David Boder: Сколько...человек?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нас 17 там [в одном месте?] [fades, weak and garbled].
David Boder: Так. Вот, значит вы [1-2 garbled] полк разбился, [расстрелялся?].
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так.
David Boder: И вас в лесу было 17 человек.
Vladus Lukosevicius: 17 в одной группке и мы хотели перейти по [1-2 garbled] большую дорогу [в шашку?]...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: и [на дорогу?] мимо ехали немцы на [1-2 garbled] другой [sic] помыкали к нам, чтобы мы подошли к ним. Как подошли, так взяли и погнали в местечко Седлец на [2-3 garbled/weak].
David Boder: А у вас было оружие [1-2 garbled]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Было...[оружие?] [1-2 weak]
David Boder: Так. Они что [говорили?] вам? Руки поднять вверх?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, когда [chuckles] [1 garbled] сказали “руки вверх,” да...
David Boder: Да,
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . и подняли руки.
David Boder: Ну, расскажите подробно. Ну, хорошо. Вас повели в небольшой городок и что?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, тогда нас вечер был [в это совсем?] [fades/garbled].
David Boder: [1-2 garbled]
Vladus Lukosevicius: В сарай догнали, но все нам сказали [1 garbled] там кругом полно было немцев и [fades].
David Boder: Так.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 144. We are going to change over to Spool 145 with a report of Mr. Vladus Lukosevicius, ah, in München, September the 21st, 1946, in a Baltic camp, in a camp for displaced Baltic people of Estonia, Lithuania and...hmm, Latvia. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.
David Boder: September the 21st, 1946, Munich, Germany, at Lohengrinstrasse, the camp for Baltic displaced persons. Lukosevicius, Mr. Vladus Lukosevicius in Russian is continuing his story.
David Boder: [In Russian] Значит вас 17 человек взяли в плен...
Vladus Lukosevicius: Взяли.
David Boder: . . . и куда вас поместили и что с вами сделали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Они нас поместили сразу в сарай [одно?] где и немцев полно было [Sounds as if he is in a tin can. 1 garbled] [там ночи на дворе?] полно было [2-3 weak/garbled]. [За утром?] нас догнали в тюрьму. Большая тюрьма была в Седлце, [в городе?]. Так, в тюрьме там нас уже собрали еще 2-3 дня там держали нас, собрались около 4,000 [уже в плен?] [2-3 garbled].
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, там [в барах дали?] кушать [на день?] хлеба там на 5 человек одну [булочку?]. После, нас гнали пешком 4,000 людей, так гнали, гнали аж [ну таких?] 170 километров. По, по 40 километров [за день?] [1-2 garbled]. Кушать ничего не давали [здоровы?].
David Boder: Ну, дальше.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Long pause, then both speak at once, all garbled] Да. Погнали...
David Boder: [Blocked by above] Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: на прусскую границу в город [Гракбова?], станция [Грабова?]. Тогда согнали по 70 человек в один крытый вагон, товарный вагон по 70 людей.
David Boder: Tak. А как вы знали, что 70?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, тогда полно было так, могли сосчитать.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Стоять, посидеть не было...места.
David Boder: Так...Ну?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Тогда повезли нас [через одну часть?] Пруссию, [1-2 garbled] окна закрыты, где мы не знали самые, целый день [везли?] после остановил нас в Рисенбургу городе.
David Boder: Только пленные были?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Пленные, только пленные были.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Тогда нас там уже в Рисенбурге было 18,000.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, стали на дворе и не под крышей, это всем холодно было, то было [под?] конец Сентября совсем.
David Boder: Да. Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, после Немцы приезжали в Больших [1-2 garbled - probable name] [из?] фабрики и забирали по несколько человек на фабрики Большие [1 garbled, probable name], так нас 30 человек отсчитали, по...погнали в баню, дезинфекцию дали и уколы дали и тогда нас...
David Boder: Уколы значит про...против болезней?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Против болезней какой-то.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, после повезли от Большой [1 garbled, possibly name. Sounds like Одноименья], которой звался тиргард.
Vladus Lukosevicius: И там мы работали [полные работы?].
David Boder: Полевые работы?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да, полевые работы.
David Boder: Какой месяц этот был?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Это было от Рисенбурга 13 километров.
David Boder: Я говорю, что [который?] месяц этот был? [Когда это было?]
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, [под?] конец сентября было.
David Boder: Так...И что вы делали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Собирали бураки, [??сукровые??] копали и картошку.
David Boder: Так. А кушать давали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Кушать тогда уже давали тоже на 5 человек, одну булку хлеба и там супу давали в обед. [Blocked by Boder].
David Boder: А эти бураки можно было кушать?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Бураки тоже [пробовали?] кушать. [Unknown number garbled.]
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [1-2 garbled]
David Boder: Ну?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, тогда мы, я там жил 3 месяца. И на там литовском, литовской национальности было [польской армии?], в этом месте нас было 11 человек.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, мы как пожили там уже 3 месяца...
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . Так, задумали убежать.
David Boder: Сколько вас задумали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: 5 человек.
David Boder: Гмм-мм. И куда [уйти уже?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Домой. Домой.
David Boder: Куда? В Литванию?
Vladus Lukosevicius: В Литванию, да.
David Boder: А там-же немцы были.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Не у нас там были тогда, не было немцев.
David Boder: А кто был?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Были большевики.
David Boder: О! Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, задумали убежать и тогда мы 11.го аг, ноября ночью отвинтили [граты?]...хорошо [1-2 garbled] окна.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Там сваривали ключ французский в кузнице...
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . и [украли?] через окно. Тогда 3 дня и 3 ночи [считали, что?] в Западную [Blocked by Boder].
David Boder: А другие не ожидали, [что?] [1-2 garbled]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Другие спали ночью. Не слышали, которые слышали, так нам были [уже?]...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . хорошие товарищи [laughs] так и они ничего не [сказали?].
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Но?] немцы в другой комнате, которые нас посматривали, были.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Но, окна были решетками и [двери?] на штабом, [это могло заключенном?]...
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . [так конечно?].
David Boder: Так...Ну?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Мы [удрали?] так 3 дня и 3 ночи через Пруссию, пока на польскую территорию вышли так ничего не имели кушать. [До?] военной одежи [нигде?] нельзя было показываться немцы.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: И на дороге просить щи, только по ветру [ночам?].
David Boder: У вас не было никаких знаков на одеже, что вы пленные?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так [как?] наша одежа была вся польская.
David Boder: Ага.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Военная одежа.
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, мы не показывалися в день. Мы шли только ночам не до дороги, а через поля, а через леса прямо.
David Boder: Так. 5 человек.
Vladus Lukosevicius: 5 человек.
David Boder: Так. И что кушали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, 3 дня ничего не кушали.
David Boder: Ну [blocked by Lukosevicius]
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Но больше не было?]
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: С собой, что [взяли?] картошки там, [сырье?] немножко, как мы думали убежать, так еще в этом мнении взяли себе там пшенного хлеба немножко, а мы по дороге 3 дня ничего [нигде не достали, полный день?] не могли никого спрашивать. [По-германски?] на что говорить не умели, и другое, что одежа военная.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, мы шли на [blocked by Boder]
David Boder: [Blocked]. Пище конечно было?
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Пище и воды?] так можно было [Blocked by Boder]
David Boder: Ну, что-же нибудь, что-нибудь да кушали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, один день кушали что с собой имели.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Взяли [то в карманы?], ничего не было так и взять.
Vladus Lukosevicius: А после 2 дня ничего не кушали.
David Boder: Ага.
Vladus Lukosevicius: И так я [и что же?] не рады [были?], что удрали. [Хотели бы, что?] [unknown number of words garbled] тоже.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, вышли на польскую территорию уже на помо-, [поможет?] там.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Тогда уже нам люди помогали, [тогда уже?] хорошо мы [жили?].
David Boder: Так. [Blocked by Lukosevicius]
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Blocked by Boder]
David Boder: На, [по?] польской территории, [это была?] [1 garbled] уже немцами?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Немцы были в деревнях, [blocked by Boder].
David Boder: Так. Но [в?] Польше поляки помогали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Поляки [1-2 garbled] очень хорошие [sic] помогали. Ночам по [штукой?] ночью, да, [спросишь нет немцев в этой деревни?] и они откажут, что нет немцев в [этой деревню?], тогда зайдем в комнату ночью и дают нам кушать, и на дорогу тогда уже было хорошо.
David Boder: Так. Ну...И куда вы [попали?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, ну так. Добирались [stammers] до советской границы, где была уже это, аг, советская - немецкая граница. [Польша?] была разделена.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, мы...дошли аж до, река идет Нарва такая.
David Boder: Да. Нарва?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нарвы...Нарев.
David Boder: Нарев. Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нарева.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, [interrupted by Boder]
David Boder: [Подождите?], приток [Нева?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Не Невы, Вислы.
David Boder: Приток Вислы на Неву.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Blocked by Boder] Нарва.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, тогда мы в этой, в этой, там на [мостах?] была стража.
David Boder: Русская!
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нет, нет, еще немецкая.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, мы через мост боялись идти, надо нам было переплыть реку Нарву [he continues to call it the Narva. It is the Narev.] Эта река Нарва [есть?] широкая довольно.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, в эт- [stops] аг, в деревине при Нарве полно было немцев.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, мы [отдельно?] решали там в [1-2 garbled], смотрели все [1-2 garbled] [немцы нас?] в ночи как уже [стремило?] так в этой деревне рыбаки жили, там были лодки.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Лодки. Так, мы в ночи [как стремило?] пошли в деревню, воровали лодку одну, [чтобы начали? [3-4 garbled] реки. Но, малая речка, которая проходила деревню к Нарве была замерз льдом уже, а большая река не была замерз. Тогда мы [принесли эту?] лодку и [съели троек?] [stammers] в лодку переплыть через реку и на- набрали [полнo льды?]. Потом опять вытащена [дырок?] в воду эту [1-2 garbled] и съели троек, переплыли через реку в другую сторону.
David Boder: А двое остались?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Двое остались. Один тогда вернулся, опять эти взял...
David Boder: Ну, так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . и перебрались через реку.
David Boder: И немцы никто [sic] не заметили.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Немцы не заметили.
David Boder: И русские не заметили?
Vladus Lukosevicius: А русские еще дальше, еще до русской границы было таких, ну...
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . километров может 20 еще.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: До этой рекой [sic]. Ну тогда, как перешли счастливо, перебрались эту реку и так незаметно перешли в совсем советскую границу совсем незаметно, не знали в этом направлении [1-2 garbled] кто нас на границе не задержал.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Настолько задержали, уже 15 километров за границы [2-3 garbled] городе...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . там советский патруль.
David Boder: Так. Ну...
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, очень хорошо с нами обходились и мы не думали, что там есть [кто зашли, поступали?] в окно, Думали, что хозяинa, что проспать через день и через ночь. [Желали?], что в день будем спать. Ну вот, [отказались?], что солдаты русские там [около 40 их спал?]. Ну, это не нас [1 garbled] [салями?] дали [2-3 garbled], хлеба дали, все, ну [stammers/2-3 garbled] делали, [не имели?] оружия такого и хорошо как с товарищами проспали мы с ними.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну тогда, на другой день, утром, уже [они?] нас [повели?] там [sic] в свою, с свою комендатуру. Расспрашивали как что [с путами?] какие, мы по-русски почти все могли говорить неплохо. Ну, так, они нас пустили домой ехать на свою родину где, где я жил.
David Boder: И [в [безверне?]?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Виленская область [где я?] жил там. Ну, пустили так мы тогда...
David Boder: Громче.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . тогда уже поездом приехали.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [1-2 weak/garbled] станцию [в Лынтупы?] и там [sic] пошел пешком уже домой. Ну, и все время ничего [было живо?].
David Boder: Немножко громче. [Boder must believe Lukosevicius is not speaking loudly enough, but he is almost too loud.]
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да. Все время жил при советской власти, но работал хозяйственным, а как...началась [blocked by Boder].
David Boder: [Вы что, крестьянин были?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да, [крестьянин?]...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . как хозяин. Ну, жил все время как в 41.ом году началась война
Vladus Lukosevicius: Тогда пришли немцы.
David Boder: А вас не взяли солдаты в плен?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Русские?
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Не взяли, не, не успели. Не было время, когда [это очень скорой?] [2-3 garbled].
David Boder: Так. Вот, немцы пришли.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да. Тогда пришли немцы. Как немцы пришли, ну тогда тоже я как [хозяйственный, ну так и хозяйственный?] [ничего же такого?]. Но только в случае могу такое рассказать уже в 42.ом году.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, в 42.ом году и...как у, у нас уже были [1-2 garbled] в [?кипиц??] [комисары?] и были это [крестьян?] [3-4 garbled], ну так, в городе Лынтупах, в Лынтупах горо(д), местечка небольшая очень. [2-3 garbled] местечка. Так, там было заказано, что немцы приедут лошадей забирать с телегами в Лынтупах местечку. Ну так, утром рано это было 42.го года, 20.го мая...
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . Свенчанский kreislandwirtschaftsfuehrer Иосиф Бек и его заместитель [?Вальтер Груль??] ехали автомобилем в Лынтупы [1 garbled] лошадей [1 garbled] [отбирать?], и 4 километра не доезжая Лынтуп город местечка, ну, какие-то партизаны убили этих немцев.
David Boder: Бека?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Бека и [?Груля??] [а то?] еще одного [какого?] лейтенанта и там...
David Boder: [?Груль??] [это?] литовец был?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нет. [?Груль??] был тоже это, [Вальтер?] [?Груль??] был заместитель [sic] kreislandwirtschaftsfuehrer...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: И один капитан какой германский и шофер и переводчица Ракаускайте [Rakauskaite].
David Boder: Ну.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, так, этих всех убили.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Только эта переводчица жива осталась, а шофер не знаю [как он?].
David Boder: Ну.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, тогда за 2 часа эт-, от, по этому случаю, после этого случая во время 2.ух часов [с нем с этого?] с Вильна...
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . приехали эсс-эсс [?сихерхайтельный??] отряд...[Both Bek’s job function and this word appear to be German pronounced as Russian words. In this case, from the German “sicherheit,” “security.”]
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . и окружил всю деревню 4 километра, в радиусе 4.ех километров. И всех мужчин от таких 18 лет, если 16 лет был [1 garbled] не мало [взрослом?] мужчина [все?] забирали. До 60 лет, до 55 так, женщины не забирали. Ну так, люди не знали ничего. Думали, что это будут, ну, помогать искать этих партизан, [что?] это сделал.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Но, они [1-2 garbled]. Всех, гмм, людей собрали и я [пытался?] ех-, ехал с Лынтуп города...
David Boder: Гм-ммм.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . и [в моем?] [?карманчике??] и меня [я к на трупе где эти?] люди стоят, один в рубашке, другой без фуражки, (1 garbled], которые стоят и что-то немцы кругом с винтовками, [на?] [2-3 garbled] винтовка кругом ходят не(мцы). Один немец [вот получился?] от этой [компании?] и зовет меня, чтобы я подходил к ним. Я еще сразу [и мне хотелся?]. Он подставил [фривольно?] и “ходи сюда.” Ну, я подошел и показал мне где [1-2 garbled] стоять. Я по-германски [sic] [blocked by Boder].
David Boder: [Blocked/garbled] стоять?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Где стоят люди. Уже около 60 мужчин уже стоят...
David Boder: Отдельно?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Отдельно, и а кругом их ход-, ходят немцы с винтовками...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . на подготовке. Ну, я тогда если не хотелось [эти?] немцы [захватил меня?] [5-6 garbled] сказал где там стоить. Я стою, ну из, я хотел спрашивать этих людей, чего [2-3 garbled] “кто вас [перегнал?],” а не [2-3 garbled], чтобы я ничего не говорил.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну тогда, за каких...еще полчаса перегнали больше людей, больше мужчин перегнали еще собранны с других деревней. Уже может было около 200, а так не могло хорошо по ним [было указать сам рассматриваться?] все от страху. Ну, и тогда уже нас с этого [?руманщки??] [моем?] [1 garbled] через [1 garbled] деревню в Лынтупы. Так, мы думали что допрос какой будет. [Будет кого-нибудь?] спрашивать, что-ли как погнали и тогда повернули на [Баранное?] поле, при лесе там есть могильник такой, и там была [калюши?] провода кругом [?городина??]. Догнали и остановили и сказали по тре-, [трех вот?] идти уже вперед. Трех вперед. [По трех так?] поставили, а там уже лежали с пулеметами и с винтовками немецкие эсс-эсс солдаты и стали стрелять. От [первой?] [1-2 garbled] [вскричать?] [1garbled] 3.ья и 4.ья, все уже стали креститься и молиться. Там один другого [1 garbled] отец с сыном и брат с братом там стал видеть, что же [нет был уже?] раньше так [прошли?] деревню. Так, каждую деревню по одном [повезли немцы?]. [1 garbled] [вошли в?] деревню [одну?] [2-3 garbled] компании [blocked by Boder].
David Boder: И вас?
Vladus Lukosevicius: [2 garbled]. “Ходите вот сюда. Ходите.” [Ну тот еще приносит тренировку?]. Тот человек не знает [на что и как?] [Unknown number of garbled words] [повезли одного уже. Каждую деревню по одном повесили?].
David Boder: И сказали за что они [1-2 garbled]
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ничего, ничего, не сказали ничего. Тогда, ну, стали стрелять так [1-2 garbled] [по трех они?] держались [все по трех?]. [После?] [1-2 garbled] [таких?] может уже пя...[stops, corrects] около 50 мужчин было убитых,
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так все, один нашелся такой [1-2 garbled] деревни [?Жиромска??] [такой?]. Так, тот хватил [1 garbled], подскочил на пулеметчиков немцев, [и успел?] пулемет отбирать. Так, в это время счастья была некоторые удрать. [Как он боролся?] с этими [pauses/interrupted by Boder]
David Boder: [1-2 garbled] один пулемет был?
Vladus Lukosevicius: С одной стороны пулемет был, с другой там я не мог посчитать [3-4 garbled] [200?]. [2-3 garbled] не в полной памяти, все [не был?]...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . в полной памяти были.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [1-2 garbled] [крестились?] и никто не знал, что делать.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, кругом стоять с автоматами и штыки на винтовках кругом, а тут, [?войнец??] [1-2 garbled] стреляют.
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, как он боролся этот такой [1-2 garbled] был мужчина, боролся с пулеметчиком [unsure of grammatical ending here] этом, так больше немцев подскочили и [с штыками его атаковали?], а я все-таки прошел каких может быть полминуты и в это время удалось нам таких может около 20 человек удрать.
David Boder: Куда [бежали?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: В лес.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Бежали?], ничего не помню [где и что, на?] [2-3 garbled] на, на этих, которые [1-2 blocked by Boder]...
David Boder: [Blocked by Lukosevicius, above].
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . и [они держали?] убитые и так прямо в лесы и [1-2 garbled] [и так нужен?], ничего даже не помню как, как, как осталось. А там стрельба была долга и там около 400 мужчин стал убитых [на тот-же день?] и доконченных. Ну, тогда на другой день...
David Boder: Все литовцы были?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Были [словаки, и тоже были?] белорусы там.
David Boder: Так. Евреи были?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Евреев не было.
David Boder: Нет. [Blocked by Lukosevicius]
Vladus Lukosevicius: [1-2 garbled] евреев [они?] уже так отдельно [2-3 garbled] [по?] деревнях [вот где-то равна поле?], вот на поле [1 garbled] человек, пришли немцы [ходи сюда?]. Тот ничего не знает, [отставил лошадь?] [1-2 garbled]. Тут подошел в [1 garbled] не пускать, “сходи с нами.” И пошел и пошел, так вот человек аг, сидел в комнате, [2-3 garbled] “ходи сюда.” Друго...Другой [еще не знали?], увидел, что все люди [ходят днем?] пошел там, как ушел [blocked by Boder].
David Boder: Да. [Кто у вас?]? [Both speaking at once. All garbled.]
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . [garbled] пошел посмотреть. И все. И так убили...Ну, тогда на другой день и [с вечером?] [blocked by Boder].
David Boder: Ну, как вы убежали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Я в лес убежал. Это, я так в [3-4 garbled] деревни каких 4 километра [1-2 garbled].
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, я убежал и [stammers] и сам ничего не помню как, что...
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . пока по памяти пришел. Ну, тогда [считался?] дому уже был.
David Boder: Домой пришел?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Домой пришел.
David Boder: Так. А вы [2-3 garbled] записали [1-2 garbled]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Они не записали ничего никак. Вот, [взяли?] [blocked by Boder]
David Boder: Это значит, что вы были [blocked by Lukosevicius].
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нет, не могли [знать?] ничего.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: И ничего [не?] искали и ничего [1-2 garbled/too weak]. Вот, взяли такой [избыли, надо устроиться?] все. Ну, тогда они доканчивали людей так, которые оставившие живые, так вот другой [полулесы?] и живые и здоровые, а неживые [была?], ну, от [2-3 garbled]. [Tак о́н/Tаком?], так, лежал, как немцы ушли. Доканчивали этих, которые еще живые. В голову стреляли со взрывными пульками.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, так...одному другому там [дальше?] 300 [1-2 garbled] может 3 человека так [отставить а по трупами?] [2-3 garbled]. [Unknown number garbled and lost as his voice fades].
David Boder: А кто [1-2 garbled] похоронил [этих?] [1 garbled]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, [после, после?] на другой день загнали людей в деревню [2-3 garbled] местечку Лынтуп и тогда копали больших [этих?] 80 метров в [в доложинье?] каналы и там ложились сколько там рядов и закопали их. А на другой день тоже была большая стрельба, так дальше по других деревней, как в Шудовцы деревне [Shudovtsy - about 2.1 km NNE of Lyntupy], так привезли там [1-2 garbled] [утром?] [2-3 garbled] автомашины по одному [1 garbled] [забинтовали?] и стреляли по одному. Так, тогда не один не удрал.
David Boder: А кто стреляли?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Немцы.
David Boder: А не, ни польские [1 blocked by Lukosevicius]
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нет.
David Boder: эссэссы или украинские эссэссы?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нет. Тогда нет. Тогда [были?]...
David Boder: [Немецкие эссэссы?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . только немецкие [потому, что они?] говорили по-немецки и мы не могли ничего с ними [делать?]. [1-2 garbled] тоже фуражка [2-3 garbled].
David Boder: [Unknown number of words garbled.]
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да, да...Да.
David Boder: Ну.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, тогда это уже на другой день [указано как?] стреляли они.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: На другой день [так уже?] стреляли в дальше уже, в дальше деревни, которые были уже больше как 4.ех километров в радиусе...Да...
David Boder: Это было около Свенчан.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Около Свенчан и Лынтуп.
David Boder: Лынтуп.
Vladus Lukosevicius: При Лынтуп. Это совсем Лынтуп.
David Boder: И что, Под...Подбродзе близко там?
Vladus Lukosevicius: В Подбродзе тоже 30 километров, вот.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Это совсем, расстрелянные, это было в Лынтупах, местечку, [при могиле?].
Vladus Lukosevicius: [При кладбище?].
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, тогда как похоронили этот большой [опять один?] на, на [пакетной?] земле, так тогда сказали [stammers] уже сравнять [немножко?], чтоб не было никакого, никакой заметки [засеет?]. А все-таки люди после ночи [стали?] засеять цветы, крестики вставили. [Ну, вот?] опять [1-2 garbled] людей, чтоб сравнять за какое время. Пять крестик [он уставит?] [1-2 garbled] насадит цветов, а что при...при дороге совсем расстреляли этих [ужасно?]. После [проведения?] на другой день, там в [?Жарки??] деревне [2-3 garbled] там [с этих?]...так...тоже там крестики вставили люди часто. И как в воскресенье идут [1-2 garbled] там полно женщин. Полно, полно [1 garbled] кричат и кричат, плачут. Но было так, что отец и [двух сынов?] убита бы [stammers] мужи [убитых этих?] жен [1-2 garbled] долго остались...
David Boder: Ну.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . так в этот случай там...Ну, после [еще?] была [?почестка??] такая в Свенчане в городе, Новые Свенчаны, в Адутишках, в Поставах, так около Новый Свенчан [43?] километра. Новый Свенчан там много расстреляли людей. [Два,?] двух священников [принесли?] католических убитых [1 garbled]. [Все тогда?] они считали немцы, что 400 людей убили, [?але??] так-как там видно [1-2 garbled] наверно около 1,000 было. [всего?] это.
David Boder: Ну, и еще [1-2 garbled] продолжалась, что за [1 garbled] были? А вы вернулись [себе?] в деревню [blocked by Lukosevicius]
Vladus Lukosevicius: Я в деревню сразу так еще [вернулся?]. После получил работу.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, после была [акция?], еще позвали нашу, нашего года рождения в амию. Это [1-2 garbled] на комиссию, на комиссию [не?] ушел.
David Boder: В немецкую армию?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да, в немецкую [не ушел?] тоже. После акции была [1-2 garbled] там окружали [уже?] все так [целого места?] [1-2 garbled] трясут лю(ди), мужчины и женщины искали.
David Boder: А [что же?] называется акция? [Что же?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Акция считали, ловить людей и вывозить их в Германию, а [1-2 garbled] в армию убрать.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так они считали акцию в 43.ем году [rest blocked by Boder].
David Boder: Ну, [blocked by Lukosevicius above] это было?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, тогда уже ничего такого, только спрятался, не показывался нигде.
David Boder: Так. Ну, и как вот это продолжалось, и что было потом?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, потом уже...
David Boder: И так это было у вас до тех пока русские пришли...[1-2 garbled] Немцов.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да. Ну, тогда уже и нас они усмирились и ничего так. А, уже в 44.ом году когда...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . приближался, пред...подвигался советский фронт близко, тогда я уже один раз ушел в город Свенчан с интересом о [2-3 garbled] германская поймала...
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . И тогда уже не пустили меня. Повезли, [я шел?] в город Шяуля́й, Шяуля́й.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: И там посадили в лагерь. И пленные русские были, много там мужчин собрали.
David Boder: И [1-2 garbled] почему как русские пленные?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нет, там был в одном бараке русские пленные военные были...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . советские. И там нас (2-3 garbled) так вот цивильных людей в другом бараке. [1-2 garbled] уже сам в районе где были [летчики?].
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Подержал?] там каких 4 дня и вывезли в Германию.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: В городе...
David Boder: У вас что было? Жена и дети?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Были тоже жена и дети.
David Boder: [Отдельно?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Дома [отстали?].
David Boder: Дома отстали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Дома отстали.
David Boder: Так, что [blocked by Lukosevicius].
Vladus Lukosevicius: Я ничего не знал где [они?]. На улице взяли [both talking at once]
David Boder: Так, на улице взяли?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да.
David Boder: И ничего.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ничего никто не знает.
David Boder: У вас есть родственников [sic], чтобы через Америку написать им ничего?
Vladus Lukosevicius: В Америке родственников таких не имею. Но, в Бразилии имею.
David Boder: Так. А вы не пробовали [2-3 garbled].
Vladus Lukosevicius: Я не пробовал.
David Boder: Так. Ну, значит дальше. И еще же вас увезли куда?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Увезли в город Герцогенбург [Herzogenburg]. Там около Герцогенбурга копали такие большие, глубокие ямы, по 3 метра с половиной и 4 метр, метра ширины. [Вставал?] такие столбы железные, как маяки [2-3 garbled] [на электрик?] и по 53 метра [вершины?]
David Boder: Зачем [1-2 garbeld]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, не знаю [1-2 garbled].
David Boder: И вот вы ямы копали.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Копал 3 месяца.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: И после этого [stop when Boder interrupts.]
David Boder: Как вас держали, как вас кормили, как с вами обращали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Обращались так, как с [скатанной?]. Кормили так, ну...не могу сказать, но уже ну как в наш, в нашей стране так свинье лучше щи кушают как они нам давали людам кушать.
David Boder: Ну [4-5 garbled], [ну, ладно?].
Vladus Lukosevicius: Утром...5 часов утром надо было [идти в ?бакаль??]. Ну, [?каль??] была как-то беленные [?нибы??] и не был соложен [3-4 garbled] [делать?] немножко так.
David Boder: А хлеба давали [тогда?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Хлеба давали утром.
David Boder: Какой этот хлеб был?...Пекли каждый день или каждую неделю?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, мы не [знали?] привозили откуда хлеб.
David Boder: “Привозили откуда хлеб”?
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Blocked by Boder, above]. Да.
David Boder: И было на нем мелкие опилки [stammers].
Vladus Lukosevicius: Было, было, опилки было.
David Boder: Аг, [в армии?], вы не знаете, что это был немецкий консервированный хлеб. Говорят, что [blocked by Lukosevicius]
Vladus Lukosevicius: А мы не знаем.
David Boder: . . . квадратные...
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да, да.
David Boder: Так, как [1-2 garbled].
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Garbled]
David Boder: Ага. А не были и потом [1-2 garbled] паковали, паковали [1-2 blocked by Lukosevicius]...
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да, да, да.
David Boder: . . . деревом.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Было это опилками кругом было [blocked by Boder].
David Boder: Да, а я...
David Boder: [In English] I want to make a remark. I couldn’t track this down, but in certain lagers they were giving a bread that is equivalent to some kind of a canned or preserved bread that was baked a long time ago and then in a compressed form so to speak kept in boxes between sawdust and then it was distributed in the ah, in the ah camps. In the lagers. Alright...
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, тогда утром дают хлеба на 5, [была квота?] на 5 человек.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: И дают немножко маргарины.
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: И тогда уже в 6 часов выезжаем на работу.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: В автомобиль и поехали. [Пока хочешь так и с этом?] хлебом [делить?].
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Тогда аж...целый день надо работать. Копать и копать землю. Выбрасывать 3 метра с половиной [верху?]. И ну как начинающую яму так и не так глубока, а так уже кончающую очень глубоко на [blocked by Boder]
David Boder: Глубоко и [2-3 garbled] квадрат.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [1-2 garbled] вверх выбрасывать и присматривает и кричать и толкают даже. Там греки работали, французы работали, аг, поляки...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну.
David Boder: [Garbled and blocked by Lukosevicius] были?
Vladus Lukosevicius: После...[?Илинь??]? Мне так и еще не пришлось [3-4 garbled]. Греков так много раз поляков били.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Мне так очень я еще старался работу как только мог, уже боялся [как?] [1-2 garbled].
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, тогда уже 16.го, 16.го...гммм...ну...ноября. Ноября 16.го [?вызначил?] нас 10 человек на окопы копать, как это в 45.ом...нет, в 4-...
David Boder: 4.ом.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . в 44.ом году.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да, окопы копать. Ну, и нас 6 литовцев и 4.ех болгаров [sic]...
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . взяли из этого лагеря...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Признали как уже, что еще можем работать и высланы на окопы.
Vladus Lukosevicius: В Deutschkreuz город около Вен-, Венгрии.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [1-2 garbled] [при?] венгерской границы. Там тоже мы жили 3 месяца, работали. Копали окопы. Там уже несколько лучше было. Немножко лучше. И немножко хлеба больше давали. Ну, и работы не так, не так тяжелая была. И меньше, меньше часов надо было работать.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Там, в э-, в этом городе Deutschkreuz 8,000 работу этих людей, которые окопы копали при [fades to nil].
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Вся?] [1 garbled] национальность. Французы были, итальянцы, поляки, русские. Литовцев было немного очень.
David Boder: Так.... Ну?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, тогда 3 месяца окопы копали эти. И после [этого уже?] подвигался в Венгрию фронт очень близко, уже слышно было, что очень близко...
David Boder: Кто?
Vladus Lukosevicius: сов-, совет уже под, [подлежал?].
David Boder: Да.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [А мы боялись?], чтобы в, в фронт в вагоне попасть [удрали?] с этих окопов.
David Boder: Кто [да?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: А, мы...
Vladus Lukosevicius: 5 человек.
David Boder: Литовцев?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Да.
David Boder: Это были люди [физиков?], которые с вами туда удрали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: А, нет, не тех...
David Boder: [Кто?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . [это?], который [1 garbled] поднялся тут здесь уже в этом.
David Boder: Так. Ну, и как вы удрали и куда вы удрали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Удрали в Вену, в Вену город приехали и там...
David Boder: Как? Приехали или пришли?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Приехали [по этом?] [possibly mispronouncing “поездом”]. По, отправлялись уже некоторые эшелоны от [?своняли??] некоторых рабочих...
David Boder: Так
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . вот уже [2-3 garbled/blocked by Boder]...
David Boder: [Blocked]
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . а мы с этим транспортом приехали в Вену. В Вене...
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . в Вене с транспорта выскочили и нашли там Литовская была [?саюнга??] так звался.
David Boder: Союз?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Литовская такая, ну, управление было.
David Boder: Так, в Вене?
Vladus Lukosevicius: В Вене.
David Boder: Так, а разве он не былa нацистской? [sic]
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нет [hesitatingly], ну...я не знаю так [там?] сказать...
David Boder: Так. И что-же вы делали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, мы там рассказали, что мы хотим уже, не хотим вернуть в этую [sic] фирму, где там работали и хотим, чтобы у [хозяина делали те?], чтобы [он уже не?] надоело нам в этих лагерях, чтобы отдох, отдохнуть немножко. Так они нам выдали такой, такую карточку, что мы только недавно шли [1 garbled] там так, так из [больницы?] [2-3 garbled] больницы пошли, и выдали документ нам ехать аж до Берлина. Ну, а мы тогда приехали...аг...[до Берлина ехали?] около Пассау и нашли...
David Boder: [Нашли?]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Аг, нашли [хозяина?].
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [?Хозяинов??] и там жили уже 7 месяцев.
Vladus Lukosevicius: В Принбахе.
David Boder: Гм-ммм.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Принбах-ам-Инн, при Инн.
David Boder: Так...Ну и потом что случилось?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Потом 8.го...[1-2 too weak] сентября.
David Boder: Ну, не важно. А потом.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Приехали здесь в лагерь, в Логенгрин [Lohengrin].
David Boder: Ну, как?
Vladus Lukosevicius: [2-3 garbled] приехали.
David Boder: Ну, [позвольте?]. Вас когда освободили?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Освободил 1.го мая.
David Boder: Кто освободил?
Vladus Lukosevicius: [1-2 blocked by Boder above] американская армия [зашла?].
David Boder: Куда?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, там где мы жили в Принбахе.
David Boder: А вы работали у [1-2 garbled/blocked by Lukosevicius]
Vladus Lukosevicius: У хозяина, у хозяина.
David Boder: Ну, скажите мне как это было, когда вы работали а потом американская армия зашла. Вы узнали, что свобода будет?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Мы знали уже, что придет [он?], все наблюдают, так слушали [совсем не будет или?] или скоро придет американская армия.
David Boder: А хозяин что говорил?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Хозяин был эсса [SA]. Этот там [both speaking at once/several missed] такой нас.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, он ничего нам не рассказал. Ничего, ничего. Политику, что [мы у него не?] спрашивали [о нем?], и нам не рассказывал ничего.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Одно?], что по-германски [sic] говорить не умел хорошо. Ну, так, вот там я работал и один поляк работал у этого хозяина.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Вот, 1.го мая поехали в лес. Ехали назад с леса с деревом и встретили американские танки уже на дороге. Так, мы еще удрали от дороги и думали, что будут стрелять. Вот, там было Солдатов несколько.
Vladus Lukosevicius: [1-2 blocked by Boder, above] германских, они все разбежались.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Но, мы [стали?] и [laughing] смеялись. Один американский солдат с танк выбросил [лычки?]. Это [2-3 garbled] я взял.
David Boder: Это чудно [1-2 garbled]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: А, не знаю. Он [на меня?] [2-3 garbled] [пока не?] стоял, он бросил [blocked by Boder].
David Boder: А, [кушать?] [1-2 garbled] они дали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, кушать мы не [получили?].
David Boder: [3-4 garbled] приехали. Они просто проезжали [2-3 garbled]?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Они остановились и обходили [все-to нас разжали?] и обходили и искали все, на, а там было волксштурмами [не скоты?]. Эссэсс солдат был [1-2 garbled] также неорганизованна.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Так, разбежали [3-4 garbled] дальше на [городе?]...
Vladus Lukosevicius: . . . которые подали все в плен. Это было около города Браунау. Браунау-Зимбах.
David Boder: [1 garbled].
Vladus Lukosevicius: Это Зимбах [куда ходили?] эти американские танки. Все [опознавались скоро?], много офицеров германских солдат шло в плен, поддавались [данные?].
David Boder: Так...Ну, и потом значит, вы, вас когда же прав-, аг, отослали сюда?
Vladus Lukosevicius: 8.го [это был?] августа.
David Boder: 45.го года?
Vladus Lukosevicius: 45.го года.
David Boder: И вы [both talking and blocking each other at once.]
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Blocked] [живу?] здесь в лагере.
David Boder: А что же вы делаете? В чем вы работаете?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, сразу не работаю, ничего [2-3 blocked by Boder]
David Boder: [Blocked by Lukosevicius, above]
Vladus Lukosevicius: [1-2 garbled] время, а после [в лес?] я иду. Ну, разделял эту [кушано?] полгода.
David Boder: Так.
Vladus Lukosevicius: А сейчас работаю тоже при выгрузки дерева.
David Boder: Так. По...Для кого вы грузите дерево?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Это для лагеря, в лагерь здесь привозить с леса, и выгружаем и складываем.
David Boder: Так. И что вы собираете делать?
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Я сейчас?] шоферский курс окончил, и сейчас [прошел экзамен?] и дал уже тут в лагере все.
David Boder: Так. А что вы собираете делать?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Я, и, как это?
David Boder: Куда вы собираете ехать? [2-3 garbled], что с вами будет?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Ну, ну [где?] [2-3 garbled] [по результате?] там [я поеду?], но если, хотел бы поехать или в Аргентину или [1 short word garbled].
David Boder: А у вас родственники в Южной Америке есть?
Vladus Lukosevicius: В Южной Америке нет, только в Бразилии есть [blocked by Boder].
David Boder: Ну, Бразилия, это южная. А вы ему писали?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нет, не писал ничего.
David Boder: Не знает он про вас?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Не знает он про меня и я ничего не знаю. И адреса не помню я.
David Boder: И про семью ничего не знаете, да?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Не знаю ничего про семью.
David Boder: А у вас сколько там детей было?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Двое.
David Boder: Сколько лет?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Одному сей, сейчас 7.ой год, девочка, а мальчик будет 3 года.
David Boder: Так, что вы с своей семьи разделили.
Vladus Lukosevicius: Разделили.
David Boder: [In English] Аг...Well, that’s the point on which we conclude the interview with Alfonsas Paulis [sic] at Lohengrinstrasse, the Baltic camp of displaced people, displaced Latvians, Estonians, Lithuanians who are here pending their fate of which most of them don’t know. They know only one thing.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы хотите вернуться обратно в Литву?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Нет, не хочу. Я знаю хорошо советов, так как я жил 2 года под ним и [2-3 weak and garbled], [и так?] я сейчас не могу вернуться. Не, не один сейчас из нас не может вернуться [2-3 garbled].
David Boder: He feels he cannot go back, he doesn’t want to go back. And so, a man at the age of 41...
David Boder: [In Russian] Вам 41 год?
Vladus Lukosevicius: 33 года.
David Boder: [In English] Ah, a man of 33, of the age of 33 is looking for a new country, a new land and a new anchor. This...Ja?
Vladus Lukosevicius: Я хотел бы же очень сильно не хочу вернуться, [чтобы?] я знаю, что ес-, если я вернусь, так я дома не увидел [все равно?]. Но если сразу как только Американцы зашли, чтобы сразу поехал, так может быть есть, а сейчас уже год [время не ехал?], так знаю хорошо, что я дома не увидел если я хотел бы [blocked by Boder].
David Boder: Почему дом не увидете?
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Garbled, only word audible is расстреляют].
David Boder: А за что? [В Литве?] вы ничего [и никуда не?] [1 garbled].
Vladus Lukosevicius: [Нет, не все?], но я знаю как [советы?]. Я лучше знаю как другие. [История?] не знают.
David Boder: Так.
David Boder: [In English] It is a fear of getting killed, of being displaced, and the fear of others that transmits itself in a group and grows. They don’t want to go back, they don’t want to go back for their families. This concludes Spool 144, 14- this concludes spool 145...at Lohengrinstrasse in the displaced people’s camp, Lithuanians, Latvians, Estonians. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording. September the 21st, 1946, in a camp maintained by the UNRRA in some special arrangement of the military government with the Germans. Quite some intricate conditions under which these camps are maintained and of which one has to get rather printed material and dated and to get a interview when someone doesn’t know how to ask a question in order to get the proper answer. We are going now over to the Greek Orthodox church to take a part of the services. And tonight we will take the choruses of the Latvians and Lithuanians.